hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this week's video
i'm going to address the question is
aging the price we pay for cancer
protection
so it seems that i have set myself an
essay question
but i was at my desk thinking about the
recent book i finished reading
p53 the gene that cracked the cancer
codes
and of one particular chapter in this
book which was cancer and aging a
balancing act
and so i suppose this chapter gave me a
little bit of inspiration to make this
video because
i think it is an interesting topic to
talk about and it will touch upon a
couple of things i've referenced in
previous videos
and so i could probably talk about this
all day
but i haven't really got time to do that
so i'm going to break it down into
sections
and i'm a simple person so we'll keep it
simple firstly i'll talk about
why i think aging could be the price we
pay for cancer protection
and of course i'll also look at reasons
why this might not be the case
and then lastly i'll give my overall
viewpoint and
main take-homes from the video and so i
put a little thought into this video
but i know that there will also be some
potential differing opinions
but i'm always interested to hear your
thoughts as well and i do enjoy reading
your comments
so as always share them below if you
have any viewpoints
but anyway what do i think is aging the
price bp
for cancer protection so i'll begin
where the book begins with my favorite
protein p53
now for those of you who don't know p53
is a pretty famous
protein i mean there's a whole book
dedicated to it
and the reason why it's so famous is
because well firstly it is a very
interesting protein
but interestingly it is mutated in more
than 50
of human cancers and this may not be
surprising once you understand the
function of p53
so p53 is a transcription factor it
up regulates the expression of different
genes within a cell
and p53 gets activated by a variety of
different stress responses within a cell
and coordinates different downstream
responses such as cell death
or cell cycle arrest depending on the
upstream signals
to help mediate the stress in the cell
and if it can't mediate the stress
it can result in cell death so in many
ways p53 is acting as a tumor suppressor
if anything goes wrong with the nacelle
it tries to mediate the response
and if it can't it will prevent that
cell from replicating and causing
further damage
which could result in tumor genesis so
what happens if you don't have
p53 nacelle well back in 1992
larry don howard generated mice that
didn't have any p53
and what he observed was that the mice
get cancer however what's really
interesting
is that in 2002 when larry tried to
regenerate
the same mice without an ep 53 just
using a different method
he accidentally generated mice with
hyperactive p53 instead
and so according to the book sure enough
the mice were well protected from cancer
but what was very surprising was that
the mice seemed to age
exceptionally fast in just a few months
they looked like very old mice
they had hunchback spines ruffled fur
gray hair
things like that according to larry and
they lived only about two-thirds of
their normal lifespan
so this bit of evidence would support
that aging is potentially the price
we pay for cancer protection and it's
also in line with george williams theory
of
antagonistic cleotropy and this theory
proposes that cellular damage
and organismal aging are caused by
pleiotropic genes
and so according to this theory
platropic genes
are genes that increase the odds of
successful reproduction early in life
but have deleterious effects later in
life and so
p53 can be used as an example in this
theory
to show that it's beneficial early in
life for protection against cancer
but the deleterious effects later in
life is that it may cause advanced aging
if you're interested in more this review
article here goes into a lot more detail
about it
as it also discusses another
evolutionary theory of aging which is
the disposable semi theory
but going back to p53 how is it
promoting aging
so a good way to understand the aging
process is through the different
hallmarks of ageing
and so there are nine different
hallmarks of aging that can be split up
into three different categories
the primary hallmarks referred to as the
causes of damage
antagonistic hallmarks which are
responses to damage
and integrative hallmarks which are
culprits of the phenotype
and so given that p53 is activated by
different causes of damage
it's interesting to look at the
antagonistic cool marks and the
integrator full marks
for example one of the downstream
responses of p53
is the induction of cellular senescence
and so one feature of cellulosin essence
is the arrest of the cell cycle so the
cell stops dividing
and so one reason why a cell might stop
dividing
is due to the shortening of telomeres
that are on the caps of dna
these telomeres help to protect the
integrity of dna
and shorten over time during cell
division and so for these reasons
once a cell has replicated so many times
referred to as the hayflick limit
the cell can enter cellular senescence
however if p53 gets mutated
or gets lost cells can bypass this
senescence
cell cycle arrest and can keep growing
which could result in tumor genesis
and cancer but this isn't the only
hallmark of senescence
another feature of senescence is the
senescence-associated
secretory phenotype and so the secretory
phenotype refers to a variety of
different molecules that are secreted
from senescent cells
these include pro-inflammatory factors
and signaling molecules
and the current theories as to why there
is such a secretory phenotype of
senescent cells
is thought to help in activating the
immune responses to be able to clear
senescent cells
which is beneficial for wound healing
and development
however if senescent cells are not
declared it can result in chronic
inflammation
that can have deleterious pro-aging
effects
and i've mentioned numerous times in
this channel
about senescent cells and their
clearance and the impact
but just to point out one study this
study showed that
in mice removing the senescent cells
delayed age-associated disorders
so summarizing what i've said so far p53
can activate
a variety of different downstream
responses one of which is cellular
senescence
and whilst these can have anti-cancer
benefits they can have pro-aging effects
and so this would be in favor of aging
being the price we pay for cancer
protection
but what about arguments against this so
arguments against this would include
either factors
that are both beneficial for cancer
protection and also beneficial for
aging so as an anti-aging
or it would be the opposite whereby it
be a process that had severe
consequences for cancer
and also caused aging now regarding the
latter
this is where the question i set myself
gets a little bit challenging because
cancer is an age-associated disease
meaning that the aging process whatever
that may be can increase the chance of
cancer development
so i guess i could have also asked is
cancer development the price we pay for
aging
but that doesn't really make much sense
because i don't think we
pay to age as much as we would pay for
cancer protection
anyway if we go back to our hallmarks of
aging we can see that another hallmark
is dysregulation of nutrient signaling
so as suggested by the name
nutrient signaling refers to different
signaling pathways within
and between cells that are active in
response to nutrient levels
an important component of nutrient
signaling is the protein
insulin-like growth factor receptor or
igf-1 receptor
and so this protein is normally
expressed within a cell
and it plays a really important role in
the regulation of cell proliferation
growth survival differentiation and cell
motility
and so as you can see in this figure
here igf-1 receptors
bind igf-1 and this can activate a
signaling pathway
which ultimately promotes growth and
inhibits processes such as autophagy
and prevents signaling of stress
resistance which can ultimately result
in aging
so effectively the igf-1 signaling
pathway is the same as that
elicited by insulin which informs the
cells
that there's presence of glucose
different genetic manipulations of this
signaling pathway
that attenuates signaling through the
pathway have been shown to extend
the lifespan of worms flies and mice
interestingly
p53 apparently also suppresses
igf-1 receptor activity by reducing the
endogenous levels of the mrna that
encodes the protein
and also stimulates the production of a
protein that can inhibit the action of
the receptor as well
in line with this mutations in p53 that
result in its loss of function
are associated with higher expression
levels of igf-1 receptor
and an increased risk of chemogenesis so
pulling all this information together
it suggests that reduced igf-1 receptor
or signaling through this igf-1 nutrient
signaling pathway as well as being able
to suppress growth of tumor cells
has beneficial effects on lifespan and
this was further seen in a human cohort
study of elderly dutch citizens
that showed that genetic variations that
caused a reduced
igf-1 signaling were beneficial for
old-age survival
so this seems to suggest that aging may
not necessarily be the price we pay for
cancer protection
however one thing that's a little bit
unclear is distinguishing between
longevity effects and aging and so maybe
reduction of this pathway
can extend lifespan but the impact on
aging
and health span may not be so clear but
these are still areas of research
under investigation so how can i pull
all this information together
well i've given both sides of the story
both reasons
for why aging might be the price for
counter protection and why it might not
be
the price and so obviously this video by
no means covers everything that we know
so far about this topic
for example there's a whole area i
haven't really touched on yet
which is how p53 can get
post-translationally modified
what that means is that different
chemical groups can be
added to p53 and this can alter its
activity
and one modification of p53 is
acetylation
and this is regulated by cert one a dsc
delays that is also dependent on nad
plus levels
and both site one and nad plus are both
also very highly connected with the
aging process
so my overall answer to this question
would be to some extent yes
and whilst that may not be necessarily
the answer you want to hear because it's
very
unclear i think it's more important to
talk about
potential factors that seem to be at the
bottom
of this case and in particular i hope
this video has
reinforced the importance of p53 in this
complicated
interaction and so i'll be interested to
hear your thoughts as well
obviously i haven't been able to mention
everything in this video
but i hope from this you've been able to
take away some insights into this very
complicated and intriguing question
and as always i hope you've learned
something and thanks for listening